quand je pense que pas secouer en bonne
santé que Michel Droit au cours des
papillote et que Thierry est mort ça me
fait chier voilà c'est étonnant non
pierre je crois que nous ne pouvions pas
faire cette émission sans adresser un
salut amical à Thierry oui alors nous
allons le retrouver dans un sketch que
nous avons vu déjà depuis quelques jours
voilà c'est quelque chose que je ressens
très profondément alors on va le repas
le genre quand je pense que pas secouer
en bonne santé que Michel Droit court
papillote et que Thierry est mort ça me
fait chier voilà on va le retrouver dans
des images qui date de 1977 c'était la
causerie au coin du feu Pierre Desproges
Thierry Le Luron
je prends finir mon général je voudrais
savoir ce que vous pensez de l'étalement
des vacances je suis pour l'étalement
sous toutes les formes pour l'étalement
je veux dire je montre bilan l'exemple
la majorité me suis voyez comme nous
nous sommes étalés aux municipales on en
fait on vient de s'étaler on peut quand
même se ramasser par la suite donc c'est
pas vrai et nous comptons nous ramasser
aussi au législatif oui bah c'est pas
c'est pas mal barré
maintenant on pourrait peut-être élever
un peu le débat si vous voulez bien et
je voudrais savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière le
personnage officiel de Valérie machin
distinct non non c'est une image pour
constituer je voudrais savoir en un mot
qui êtes-vous VGA
s'il vous plaît je pense que je suis
humble avant tout car comme le disait si
bien Montaigne si haut que l'on souhaite
assis
comme le disait si bien Montaigne ce
n'est jamais que sur son derrière oui
vous en fichez vous vous situez
au-dessus des parties donc c'est vrai
dire que ça je pense d'ailleurs que je
conduirai la majorité puisque vous le
savez dans quelques temps il y aura un
choix à faire oui justement je voulais
vous poser la question je vous en avais
prévu qu'on la poserait
vous êtes gentil vous coupez comment les
pas en direct
je voudrais pas que les Français
imaginent que le président connaît les
questions
bon c'est pas en direct
je ne connais pas les questions à
l'avance je ne connais que les réponses
alors on reprend l'âge avec Pierre et
puis voilà on va repartir le ministre en
chef je voudrais savoir
la grande question que tout le monde se
pose sauf moi parce que moi
c'est dans 6 mois d'ici maintenant les
Français
auront un choix à faire et bien j'espère
que ce sera un bon choix madame bon
choix manuel bonsoir monsieur
que j'ai trouvé très jolie c'est que il
a exigé que quand on vend d'aucun livre
n'est aucun disque qu'on grave aucun
disque et qu'on écrive aucun livre et
surtout qu'on vende pas sa mort comme
certains marchands en fait celle de
Coluche je trouvais ça c'est bien
humainement
allez on rigole merde
[Musique]